to you said something about how on the
spiritual side like you're allowed to
kind of repent I don't whoa no I don't
know is that what you meant uh no
because repentance is basically saying
okay I'm now absolved from all my sins
okay cool but I I understand the whole
religious aspect but my mind's more like
spiritual and you said you can kind of
cleanse like yeah you can cleanse so and
so my point would be for the cleansing
bit like you still have mileage on the
clock yeah you know what I mean yeah so
whether you've cleansed or not these
things have happened but does the
mileage sit in you though yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
if you're if your situation put you to a
mileage of sixty thousand whether you
cleanse or not you're still at sixty
thousand maybe you're not trying to get
any more but like you you still at 60
000 you don't go back you can